today I'm standing in front of the
global headquarter of Allianz and today
we are going to learn what the day in
the life of a Project Lead at Alliance
Consulting looks like hi hi Liz nice to
meet you hi Vanessa the pleasure is mine
and welcome to Allianz so Heinrich I
just show you what it's all about sounds
great I'm working I'm currently on a
project within customer experience and
today we'll actually meet the client the
stakeholders were very happy with the
results and they're looking forward to
the next steps so we're going to meet
Stefan Schmidt he's the head of Allianz
Consulting we are really dealing with
the core of what it is about in changing
the insurance industry to be fit for the
future
what is the mission and vision of
Allianz Consulting would you mind just
sharing a very personal Journey how is
this all work from home thing working
out for you
and I hope that for everyone in the
audience there are some good insights on
in-house Consulting on Alliance
Consulting as well thank you
[Music]